Miami out rebounded the Knicks in game
four 44-35 Brunson all the way Coast to
Coast for Jalen Brunson he's trying to
get the NY back
and he he's only can right now Nina
yes Brunson
a shot for Grimes in the corner Haywood
Highsmith in the game for Miami Lowry
was online but too strong Obi top it in
for New York love it up
[Applause]
Smith sticks with Brunson Bounce It
two-man game with hartenstein Brunson
that's your drop
timeout Heat
Brunson gets into it quickly fend off
floater good
what you notice the big difference here
at the beginning
of this second quarter yes they're
making baskets step back
when Robinson was spaced up in the
corner to contest that shot
there's no way Robinson expected to pass
that at all he was looking at trying to
get in position in case the shot came
out foul on Duncan Robinson
[Applause]
better care of guarding your man
one-on-one and not getting broken down
off the dribbles as soon as you get into
help Moe Robinson is going to be lurking
somewhere behind the three-point line
Brunson pull up
[Applause]